former president bill clinton remains in
a southern california hospital after
being admitted tuesday to treat a
non-covert related infection
former first lady hillary clinton was
seen leaving the hospital alone
on friday it's unclear when the 42nd
president will be released lilia luciano
reports
former president clinton's condition is
improving with doctors saying he's
responding well to treatment but when he
was admitted tuesday to the irvine
medical center there were signs of
danger he was disoriented he wasn't
speaking clearly he was nauseous he had
vomiting and they were very scared the
75 year old former president was
suffering from an untreated urinary
tract infection and showing signs of
sepsis a serious infection of the blood
it's very dangerous i mean you know
literally hours a day later he could
have died from the infection and so i
think we're lucky that he was near an
excellent hospital that his team pushed
him to go to the hospital right away and
get the care he needed since then he's
been up walking and talking and has two
books with him former first lady hillary
clinton has been by his side and
president biden called him he's doing
fine he really is
and he's going to release from the
hospital and we talked about
which we were going to do before getting
together i haven't seen him in a while
i'm going to come over and have some
lunch and talk doctors stressed mr
clinton's hospitalization is not hard or
coveted related but he has suffered
several major health scares since
leaving the white house including
quadruple bypass heart surgery in 2004
and he had two stents inserted to open
one artery in 2010. his representatives
say president clinton has continued to
respond well to the antibiotic treatment
for cbs saturday morning lilia luciano
irvine california